ich habe Gänsehaut nur keine gute du
niemanden mit dem ich darüber reden
konnte man ist mal kurz zur Toilette
gegangen und hat kurz mal heulen können
für 12 Minuten während man sich
erleichtert hat
das Thema Pflege scheint ja derzeit
etwas breit getreten oder fast schon tot
getreten und die Situation hat sich doch
jetzt endlich entspannt oder nicht sie
hat sich entspannt aber nur von der
Corona Situation sie hat sich entspannt
von ach du heilige Scheiße auf
einfach nur noch scheiße während Corona
musste man immer wieder erklären dass
auf der Intensivstation nicht fehlen der
Betten das Problem sind sondern
fehlendes Personal doch dieses Problem
ist leider alt hier ein Beitrag vom NDR
von 2018
Personalproblem
macht daraus eine Abstellkammer und es
könnte noch schlimmer werden 2019 sorgte
eine Befragung von rund 2500
Intensivpflege Kräften für diesen Titel
Versorgung der Bevölkerung in Gefahr
37% der Befragten gaben an dass sie
innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre ihren
Beruf verlassen wollen #brexit exit aus
der Pflege
[Musik]
liebe Menschen würde zu tun ganz banales
Beispiel Mann liegt im Bett ist schon
etwas älter körperlich nicht mehr so auf
der Höhe dass man viele Dinge nicht mehr
alleine machen kann und man muss
Stuhlgang lassen oder man muss mal Pipi
machen und das ist halt einfach so wenn
man krank ist passiert seit auch ins
Bett in die Windel und wenn man dann
stundenlang in den eigenen Ausscheidung
liegen muss bevor der nächste Pflege
oder die Pflegerin kommt um einen da
rauszuholen und ihr könnt mir glauben
ich sehe sowas öfter auf Arbeit dann ist
das kein Zustand den sich irgendjemand
auch nur annähernd wünschen kann
alt und analysiert für euch was sie ganz
konkret für die Pflege tun wollen findet
ihr in der infocard oder später in der
endcard ok der öffentlichen Diskussion
und die Pflege geht es oft um die
Entlohnung ums Gehalt tatsächlich sind
ausgerechnet systemrelevante Berufe
unterdurchschnittlich bezahlt und nicht
nur das hier genießen auch
unterdurchschnittliches Prestige also an
sie in der Gesellschaft systemrelevant
aber schlecht bezahlt und wenig
angesehen hier liegt also eine
Schieflage ein Ungleichgewicht vor das
natürlich zu Frust Unzufriedenheit führt
aber es gibt noch mehr Faktoren die in
dieses Gleichgewicht rein spielen die
ist verstärken oder abmildern können und
da schauen wir uns jetzt mal genau an
eine Frage des Gleichgewichts wirst du
für deine Anstrengung
angemessen belohnt bekommst du raus was
du reinsteckst das ist die Frage die
hinter dem PRI Modell steht EMI steht
für Effert reward imbalance oder auf
Deutsch anstrengungs belohnungs
Ungleichgewicht wenn Anstrengung und
Belohnung im Ungleichgewicht sind für
das nicht nur zur Brust sondern
langfristig auch zu chronischem Stress
und erhöht das Risiko für bestimmte
Krankheiten von Burnout über
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen bis hin zu
Depressionen es gibt einen eri
Fragebogen die man in soziologischen
Studien einsetzt er fragt folgende
Sachen ab das Ausmaß der Anstrengung die
ein Job verlangt die Belohnung hier
gibt's drei Unterpunkte Wertschätzung
Gehalt und Aufstiegschancen und
Jobsicherheit und zuletzt ein sehr
spannender. Namens overcommitment
erkläre ich gleich gehen jetzt mal
gemeinsam diesen Fragebogen durch und
ihr könnt reflektieren wie es in eurem
Job aussieht und wir wollen natürlich
von ricardo wissen was seine
persönlichen Erfahrungen sind. 1
Anstrengung aufgrund des hohen
Arbeitsaufkommens besteht häufig großer
Zeitdruck bei meiner Arbeit werde ich
häufig unterbrochen und gestört bei
meiner Arbeit habe ich viel
Verantwortung zu tragen ich bin häufig
gezwungen Überstunden zu machen meine
Arbeit ist körperlich anstrengend im
Laufe der letzten Jahres meine Arbeit
immer mehr geworden
und man hat ja an sich selber auch so
ein gewisses
also dann und dann Anspruch seine Arbeit
ordentlich zu machen und der sparen hat
selber vorgegeben dass ein
Intensivpfleger im Tagesgeschäft zwei
schwerkranke
intensivpflichtige Patienten betreuen
sollte ist leider nicht immer möglich
oder fast nie wir betreuen drei oder
vier Patienten das führt dann dazu dass
ich meine Aufmerksamkeit aber auch auf
drei oder vier Patienten aufteilen muss
und dann haben wir manchmal wirklich
Patienten die sind so schwer krank dass
er von diesen Bett eben nicht weg kommt
jetzt hat man aber noch zwei oder im
schlechtesten Fall drei andere Patienten
die sind genauso schwer krank und die
Fallen daneben finden runter und man
weiß eben gar nicht mehr wie man das
alles schaffen soll oftmals ist eben so
dass man immer wieder einspringen muss
also an dem Wochenende wo man vielleicht
frei hätte hat man eben doch nicht frei
und ja man gibt's dann eigenes
Sozialleben auf um eben den Patienten
helfen zu können.
[Musik]
Kings W einer entsprechenden wichtigen
Person die Anerkennung die ich verdiene
ich halte in schwierigen Situationen
angemessene Unterstützung ich werde bei
deiner Arbeit ungerecht behandelt wenn
ich ein Aldi erbrachten Leistungen und
Anstrengungen denke halt dich die
erfahrene Anerkennung für angemessen
meine Meinung für Wertschätzung ist das
mal unabhängig von der Welt da draußen
wir Pflege Kräfte und selber anfangen
sollten wertzuschätzen denn wir haben
auch eine Gesundheit wir haben auch ein
Privatleben wir müssen einfach auch so
selbstbewusst werden auch mal Nein zu
sagen wenn mich erst wenn wir uns selber
anfangen wertzuschätzen können wir das
auch von anderen einfordern.
aber mit Sicherheit auch jeder andere
Krankenpflege einen anderen
Fachabteilungen
machen muss die Verantwortung die man
hat den Stress den man hat die soziale
ich sag jetzt mal
Isolation die man zum Teil hat weil man
hat ja nicht wirklich ein Sozialleben
weil man immer dann arbeitet wenn andere
frei haben und umgekehrt ist die
Bezahlung in meinen Augen nicht
angemessen wer sie denn angemessen würde
es genug Menschen geben die diesen Beruf
ja machen und wie jeder weiß gibt es
dann hohen Personalmangel die Aufstieg
Chancen sind in der Pflege super wenn
man sie dann nutzen möchte und auch
nutzt aber dazu braucht man natürlich
auch genug Personal weil man muss wissen
dass jeder der jetzt so wie ich jetzt am
Bett steht und einen Studiengang besucht
und wird zB ja Pflegedienstleitung der
fehlt der am Bett und deswegen sind auch
die Kliniken bisschen sparsamer damit
weil jede Pflegekraft die sich
weiterbildet und weg vom Bett geht fehlt
nachher am Ende ne
Belohnung
Jobsicherheit ich erfahre und erwarte
eine Verschlechterung meine
Arbeitssituation mein eigener
Arbeitsplatz ist gefährdet der
Pflegeberuf ist in der Sicherheit bastel
die Anstellung angeht super weil weiß er
bestimmt jeder dass Pflegekräfte überall
fehlen und somit wird man immer eine
Stelle irgendwo finden Problem ist aber
nur dass man eine Stelle finden muss wo
man sich wohlfühlt eben die Umstände vor
Ort nicht dazu führen dass man dann
längerfristig dort bleibt heutzutage.
es passiert mir oft dass ich schon beim
Aufwachen an Arbeitsprobleme denke wenn
ich nach hause komme fällt mir das
Abschalten von der Arbeit sehr leicht
diejenigen die mir am nächsten stehen
sagen ich opfere mich zu sehr für meinen
Beruf auf
die Arbeit ist nicht selten los das geht
mir abends noch im Kopf rum
wenn ich etwas verschiebe was ich
eigentlich heute tun müsste kann ich
nachts nicht schlafen
bringe sie eigentlich jetzt in der
Korona Pandemie
mein Hund war krank und ich wollte mich
eigentlich nächsten Tag ja von der
Arbeit abmelden weil mein Hund eben den
ging es wirklich nicht gut und wir waren
auch beim Tierarzt und hätten nächsten
Tag wieder zum Tierarzt gewusst und da
teilte man mir am Telefon mit dem
Ricardo nee bitte, da fehlen schon so
viele Leute wenn du es nicht mehr kommst
dann ist alles vorbei und der Mann hat
seine eigenen Bedürfnisse wieder runter
geschraubt ist zur Arbeit gefahren und
ja um 9 Uhr wäre der Tierarzt Termin
gewesen aber um 8 Uhr bekam ich dann die
Nachricht dass mein Hund verstorben ist
mitten auf der Arbeit und ich hatte an
diesem Tag Frühdienst am Sonntag werde
ich nicht vergessen hatte vier Patienten
zu betreuen statt zwei also wirklich
viel und musste diesen harten
Schicksalsschlag runterschlucken musste
konzentriert bei der Arbeit bleiben
hatte niemanden mit dem ich darüber
reden konnte man erst mal kurz zur
Toilette gegangen und hat kurz mal
heulen können für 12 Minuten während man
sich erleichtert hat und musste dann
wieder hoch konzentriert zur Arbeit
gehen und das ganze ist jetzt ja fast
ein Jahr her und ich fühle mich heute
noch als Verräter weil man den besten
Freund den man hat also der Hund ist ja
für viele der beste Freund und
Familienmitglied in seiner schwersten
Zeit im Stich gelassen hat weil man auf
der anderen Seite aber seine Kollegen
nicht in Schlüssel außen wollte wenn man
die Patienten nicht im Stich lassen
wollte und ja und das ist für mich
wirklich ein sehr prägendes Ereignis wo
ich heute noch mit zu tun habe ich ein
jetzt offen drüber sprechen weil ich
jetzt schon mehrmals darüber gesprochen
habe aber es fiel mir am Anfang wirklich
schwer und der Hund die ganze Überladung
an Arbeit an Stress führt eben dazu dass
man in den Urlaub geht und jeder der
jetzt z.b. Urlaub hat der freut sich
aber ich gehe in den Urlaub und ein
Tages vorbei und denke ich arbeite schön
endlich Urlaub sondern ich sage mir auch
jetzt ist schon wieder ein Tag von den
Urlaub rum einen Tag den du weniger frei
hast und der Dir quasi von deiner
Freizeit ja flöten geht und man hat also
wie so eine Sanduhr die langsam abläuft
wo man dann genau weiß morgen musst du
wieder arbeiten und man kann eigentlich
den ganzen Urlaub nicht richtig
entspannen weil man immer wieder Angst
vor dieser Arbeitsbelastung hat wenn man
ganz genau weiß bis zum nächsten Urlaub
da wird noch eine Weile vergehen man
muss einfach wissen dass man immer immer
zu einer erpressbar ist weil man eine
Verantwortung hat für Leben und für
Gesundheit von Menschen die auf unsere
Hilfe angewiesen sind
was hat meine Arbeit für einen Sinn das
Gefühl hast du wahrscheinlich nicht oder
doch manchmal frage ich mich selber was
hat meine Arbeit für einen Sinn wenn man
seine Arbeit eben nicht so erfüllen kann
wie man es gerne hätte also warum ich
Intensivpfleger ich möchte mich um
schwerstkranke Menschen kümmern wenn ich
aber auf Arbeit bin und meinen eigenen
Anspruch jedes mal verraten muss also
ich muss quasi meinen eigenen Anspruch
runterschrauben muss mit ansehen wie
Patienten darunter leiden dann frage ich
mich doch häufig schon wo ist der Sinn
deiner Arbeit warum machst du das
überhaupt noch also für mich steht
Festival de Cannes wenn ich aus diesem
Beruf weg
ein toller Beruf ist das sind Professor
Katja wo gut und Professor Johannes
gräske von der ASH Hochschule in Berlin
beide waren viele Jahre selbst als
Pflegekräfte tätig und das da ist das
Manuskript einer Studie die sie ganz
frisch eingereicht haben es handelt sich
um eine wissenschaftliche Befragung von
Pflegekräften unter anderem zu deren
anstrengungs belohnungs Balance unter
den knapp 2700 Befragten hier gehen sie
es nicht nur um Intensivpflege sondern
um alle Pflegeberufe denken knapp 40%
darüber nach aufzuhören ein
Krisenszenario auch das ist ein Szenario
sicherlich was ich viele gar nicht so
vor Augen führen aber für mich hatte
Pflegeaufwand 1 ähnliches Ausmaß wie der
Klimawandel auf den wir zusteuern ich
glaube das ist viel noch gar nicht so so
bewusst die Probleme die wir heute schon
sehen werden in Zukunft nur schlimmer
weil unsere Gesellschaft immer älter
wird lautet dieser Prognose kommen im
Jahr 2060 auf 100 Menschen zwischen 20
und 64 Jahren
und 50 Menschen die über 65 Jahre alt
sind das betrifft eben dann auch Emden
sicherlich nicht mehr meine Generation
sondern die Generation der jüngeren die
dann auch viele Menschen pflegerisch zu
versorgen haben seist ihr eigenen Eltern
oder m in der Nachbarschaft Freunde weil
es einfach keine ambulanten
Pflegedienste mehr gibt oder auch keine
Pflege im stationären Pflegeeinrichtung
wenn dieser Beruf nicht unterstützt wird
dann landet das im Prinzip bei der
Gesellschaft
von den Pflegekräften passiert gar
nichts bin seit seit vier Jahren
berufspolitisch unterwegs und ich
verzweifel zum Teil aber auch nicht nur
an den Politikerinnen und Politikern
sondern auch teilweise an der eigenen
Berufsgruppe ja also diese
Leidensfähigkeit so einerseits und auf
der anderen Seite dann aber so mit den
Füßen abzustimmen und zu gehen dass das
ist glaube ich das ganz große Problem
sehr wichtiger. Inzwischen alles
erdulden und alles mit sich machen
lassen und die Schnauze komplett
Vorhaben und gehen dazwischen ist ja
noch was nehme ich für sich einstehen
sich für seine Interessen stark machen
sich organisieren in Gewerkschaften die
unter anderem für bessere Gehälter und
Arbeitszeiten kämpfen und in
Berufsverbänden in pflegekammern die für
die fachlichen Arbeitsbedingungen für
die Qualität der Pflege einstehen
nur noch auf Station
soll ich also das ist dieses
Selbstverständnis ist ist schwierig zu
verändern im Pflegeberuf das ist es wird
immer gewartet dass irgendwer anders
kommt und etwas verbessert und das
passiert aber nicht ich war fassungslos
wir hatten in einigen Bundesländern es
ja erreicht das ist berufliche
pflegekammern gab und die sind ja dann
auch in Umfragen im Nachgang von der
Berufsgruppe wieder selber abgeschafft
worden und hier wird mir auch noch mal
bewusst also wie wie wenig hier
vielleicht auch Zusammenhänge verstanden
werden
sondern auch meine Kollegen und
Kolleginnen halten wir das System nicht
mehr funktioniert und
deswegen wird sich nichts ändern
harte Realität auch wenn es eigentlich
eine Sauerei ist es ist eine Sauerei
dass ihr für euch kämpfen müsst es
sollte eigentlich in dem Interesse von
jedem einzelnen von uns sein dass die
Bedingungen für diesen wichtigen Beruf
gut sind hier muss endlich die Politik
an die Arbeitsbedingungen run moin von
dir da oben den Politik Format bei Funk
in der Politik wieder viel geredet aber
was sind die konkreten Pläne was will
man tun das hat Jan für euch analysiert
wenn ihr genau wissen wollt wie die
Pflege laut unseren Parteien in Zukunft
aussehen soll kriegt hier und checkt
mein Video angeschaut da unbedingt
vorbei vor könnten uns doch in die
Kommentare schreiben was ihr persönlich
aus dem eri Fragebogen mitnehmen konntet
wir sehen uns bald bis dahin bleibt
sicher